à la fin des années 2000 plusieurs
scandales dans le monde de la
construction sont révélés entre autres
par l'émission enquête de radio canada
plusieurs réclament alors une commission
denquête que le gouvernement de jean
charest est d'abord réticent à mettre
sur pied sa première réponse sera plutôt
policière il y aura l'opération marteau
puis l'unité anticollusion et enfin
l'upac l'unité permanente anticorruption
est créée en février 2011
inspiré du department of investigation
de la ville de new york
l'upac est dirigée par un commissaire
nommé par le gouvernement depuis le
début
il s'agit de robert lafrenière elle est
composée de 350 membres qui proviennent
de différents organismes dont la sûreté
du québec et le service de police de la
ville de montréal sa mission prévenir et
lutter contre la corruption collusion
trafic d'influencé
dans l'attribution des contrats publics
le projet de loi censé actuellement à
l'étude
fred l'upac un corps policier à part
entière ou commissaires auraient une
plus grande marge de manoeuvre pour
mener à bien ses enquêtes
les pouvoirs de l'upac serait élargie il
viserait non seulement le volet
contractuels de la fonction publique
mais aussi toute la fonction publique
elle-même
parmi les succès de l'upac depuis six
ans on compte l'arrestation de l'ex
maire de laval gilles vaillancourt et
celle de l'ex maire de montréal michael
applebaum tous deux reconnu coupable de
corruption
l'upac a aussi arrêté effet accusé
nathalie normandeau
l'ex vice première ministre du québec